you are good but you know here's the
thing
a lot of people are still on that old
model oh this is what i was saying to
that person um
look at a show like the bachelor okay i
hate it
i've never seen it i love it but it's so
super popular it's been on forever yeah
it's corny as [ __ ]
why is it so popular because lots of
people
most are still corny as [ __ ]
they still are on this model
of
oh there's the one perfect person and
i'm going to like find this person like
an egg in an easter hunt and then we're
going to be happy forever this fairy
tale i'll tell you what i hate it and
sometimes it works once in a while like
with you it did and i meant your beauty
it would have never happened for me on a
bachelor
no i'm but i'm just saying
like that tells you a lot about where
people still are a lot of people are
still there and then there's just
zillions of people who are beyond that
model including women women are so
different than they were when i was
first dating because back then it was
like i gotta find a man and now it's
like you know what if i find a man and
it works out and it's the right move
yeah i'm good for that but if i don't
find a great one
that's fine too i can just do me and be
me and i don't need a man
if it if i find a great one good if i
don't sign ndas
what have you ever had a no i don't need
to
i wouldn't be with someone who i needed
to sign an nda with
it's it's a you know there's something
about
just discerning people's character
how about just that
that takes
you know you discern somebody's
character that people are together for a
decade and then find out this is not the
person i thought it was and what i was
talking about a decade well that then
something has changed in that decade we
all change
that's true which is why i one reason
why i never got married because things
can and do change the thing about you
you brought up the bachelor the
bachelorette this is what i hate about
it i watch it i can't you know it's like
a train wreck for me i watch it i think
it's well done i hate to watch it i hate
watch it and i'll tell you why it
doesn't make and i laugh at it and i
think a lot of people a lot of people
take it seriously but i find because
there's a bachelor or a bachelorette
there are how many people started like
25 people
vying
and vying for this one person that you
don't [ __ ] know
you have nothing in common with and they
go out on these dates and and they go i
don't know that you're here for the
right reason no i'm here for the right
reason i want to find true love true
love is a [ __ ] stranger on a on a
reality show also would always amused me
about that show is that they compared it
to a harem because it's a guy and
there's 20 girls around him okay in a
harem you add
women this one you're subtracting
there's no harem in the world that works
that way where the king in morocco who
does have a harem i believe uh
constantly is letting them go he's
adding them that's because a lot of uh
maybe if he was dyslexic maybe he would
he would let them go but it was like
remember who wants to marry a
millionaire that was the first of course
so that was the first reality show but
it was just so
uh disappointing to me and that's what i
was asking you about it was like they
were what was attractive about him they
said he had a million it turned out he
didn't he was a comic remember you start
with you're thinking of joe millionaire
is that joe millionaire he was a comic
he was a hockey player he was he was a
fake millionaire he wasn't a real
millionaire who wants to marry a
millionaire was
i don't remember maybe i'm thinking joe
millionaire who wants to be a
millionaire i'm mixing those two well
joe millionaire was like a goof on the
women who thought he was a millionaire
and then they find out that's the twist
was that he really wasn't a millionaire
i guess so do you still love him
right so my point is it just shows you
that our society is set up and we watch
where
you as a millionaire or as somebody
famous you are somewhat of a target i
feel like it's degrading women too to
say that women are only after men for
money necessarily all the time thank you
like why are you worried about that
maybe men are after money too and all
the wrong things as well there's plenty
of women out there who are humans or
there's plenty of women out there that
aren't after a person for the wrong
reasons right that's thank you very much
i think the majority of people are out
there for the wrong reason
uh will you stay married well avoid them
you know avoid those people
you think at this point in my life i
can't smell that a mile away
i don't know i don't know how out there
you are i can smell it a mile away you
think i know
i don't know i don't have a retort
because because i'm me and i'm living my
life and you know it's like i always say
to people
but you you've had in in in the past
you've had uh relationships kick you in
the ass a little bit of course who
hasn't right so
so you you obviously you weren't meaning
much everyone has that though you don't
have to be you guys to have
relationships kick you in the ass right
but you didn't read somebody the right
way you didn't know how that would turn
out
i mean the
there's no nothing in my life that ever
caused me more pain
than my first breakup to this day and i
was 17 years old really yeah where is
she now who
i don't know i'd be very curious but i
don't know what's her name let's see
let's look her up
google her no
i mean i've thought of that but i mean
she's probably a grandmother now
um
but
yeah nothing might be single to this
well i think that bus has sailed uh
but really to this day
because the first time you're dubbed
is so devastating because you don't see
it coming and you don't know you'll
outlive it the pain of it um i mean
there was at least a year
a year a full year after that when i was
just miserable
24 7.
and nothing like that has quite ever
happened again i've had misery in my
life and pain in a lot of different ways
as we all have
but nothing quite like that so yes i do
you think that scarred you do you think
that's yeah maybe that kind of i think i
i do remember thinking after that okay
there's two ways to happiness in life
relationships or
work
um
maybe you should put your eggs in the
basket of the one you can control
and not that i haven't had love and
have it now
i don't think you can live without love
i don't i wouldn't want to i have it's
it's not a it's not a good way to live
and it's and you're just not happy
but as far as like what i can count on
i mean you can count on yourself or at
least i can
um do you in
let's move on from relationships just to
your relationship with the world in this
you know we always talk about can you do
cancel culture and and comedy and yeah
you live in a world
you know just i think your
milieu is being honest and authentic and
we are so [ __ ] polarized
that uh you know
it's gotten somewhat dangerous i think
yeah and uh do you not concern yourself
at all with your like even your personal
safety or when you go out and somebody
sees you and they don't have the same
opinion as you politically well the
thing is i've lived with this for a very
long time before anybody else right
everybody else is just coming upon it
now right but i've had this i mean i've
had the fbi in my dressing room on a
number of occasions are you serious yeah
just to warn me about
isis or the ku klux klan or you know
whoever just isis i'm worried about i
was talking about dave from pacoima
and and now it's dave from bacoma also
um but i i mean i've had this i mean
i've had all all manner of that and
i can't do what i do and be who i am and
never really think about that if if that
day happens
i hope it's like the sopranos the end of
the sopranos where it just goes to black
[Music]
you